hi everyone et is all over the
announcement of Nick vile as the new
bachelor we have tons of insider details
so let's get to it
first we're hearing producers picking
Nick was a pretty last-minute decision
our source says Luke Pell was quote all
set to be the bachelor something bad boy
Chad Johnson also told us exclusively
today I feel like they definitely made a
switch they were doing a whole bunch of
promotional things with him you know all
after the Bachelorette so I seem like
for sure it was definitely gonna be
loose but our source says ABC was seeing
how much fans were loving Nick on this
season of bachelor in paradise so the
switch was made and we couldn't agree
more et has been championing Nick all
season long on paradise he's mature
grounded and funny on the show you seem
very happy yeah I'm happy how are you
feeling now in paradise nick has been
getting cozy with Jen Saviano so did
Nick and Jen split so that he could
become the bachelor well I will say this
I was on set in Paradise and talked to
Jen herself just before the finale was
taped here's what she said at the time
would you want him to propose tomorrow I
wouldn't want him to propose tomorrow no
we're just not there yet I did come in
in the middle of this our relationship
is moving at a very normal pace I'm very
happy with where we're at it's just I
don't know if it's enough right now
certainly not enough for an engagement
he's had a guard up this whole time and
he's been on the show twice and he got
burns twice and so I think that's
definitely on his mind Jen also told me
that she thought she and Nick might have
problems when the show ended because
they were long-distance but what do you
guys think of Nick as the new bachelor
let me know over on Twitter
you